Professor Ben Polak: So
last time we finished up by
playing the game of Nim and
you'll remember,
I hope, that the game of Nim
was a game where there was two
piles of stones--we made do with
lines on the board--and the
winner was the person who picked
up the last stone.
Remember you had to pick piles.
I want to use the game of Nim
to make a transition here.
So what we had pointed out
about the game of Nim was it
illustrated very nicely for us
that games can have first mover
advantages or they can have
second mover advantages.
A very small change in the
game, essentially a very small
change in where we started from,
could switch a game from a game
with a first mover advantage to
a game with a second mover
advantage.
Now today, I want to just draw
a slightly grander lesson out of
that game.
So not only was it the case
that the game sometimes has
first mover advantages and
sometimes has second mover
advantages,
but moreover,
we could tell when it had a
first mover advantage and we
could tell when it had a second
mover advantage.
Is that right?
When we actually looked at the
initial set up of those stones,
we knew immediately that's a
game in which Player 1 is going
to win,
or alternatively,
we knew immediately that's a
game which Player 2 is going to
win.
Now it turns out that that idea
is very general and actually has
a name attached to it,
and that name is Zermelo.
So today we'll start off by
talking about a theorem due to a
guy called Zermelo,
and the idea of this theorem is
this.
We're going to look at games
more general than just Nim,
and we're going to ask the
question,
under what circumstances would
you know about a game either
that Player 1,
the person who goes first,
can force a win,
or that Player 2 can force a
win, or will allow a third
possibility,
which is it's going to be a tie.
So here's the theorem,
suppose there are two players
in this game,
like the games that we looked
at last time,
and suppose--I won't define
this formally now--but suppose
the game is a game of perfect
information.
So what do I mean by perfect
information?
I'll define this later on in
the class, but for now all I
mean is, that whenever a player
has his turn to move,
that player knows exactly what
has happened prior in the game.
So, for example,
all these sequential move games
we've been looking at are moves
of perfect information.
When I get to move I know
exactly what you did yesterday,
I know what I did the day
before yesterday and so on.
So it's a game of perfect
information.
I'm going to assume that the
game has a finite number of
nodes.
So two things here,
it can't go on forever,
this game, and also there's no
point in which it branches in an
infinite way.
So there's a finite number of
nodes, and we'll assume that the
game has three possible
outcomes.
Actually there's a more general
version of this theorem but this
will do for now.
The three possible outcomes are
either a win for Player 1,
so I'll call it W_1,
or a loss for Player 1,
which is obviously a win for
Player 2, or a tie.
So the game--like Nim last
time, that only had two
outcomes.
So here we're going to look up
to three outcomes or three or
fewer outcomes I should say.
So these are the conditions and
here's the result.
So I said three,
it could be three but it could
also be two here,
I'm just allowing for three.
(One is trivial.) So under
these conditions the following
is true.
Either Player 1 can force a
win, so either it's the case
that this game is a game that if
Player 1 plays as well as they
can,
they're going to win the game
no matter what Player 2 does.
Or 1 can at least force a tie,
which means Player 1 can play
in such a way that they can
assure themselves of a tie
regardless of what Player 2
does.
Or it could be a game in which
2 can force a loss on 1,
so a win for 2.
So this theorem,
when you first look at it,
it doesn't seem to say very
much.
You're staring at this
thing--you might think,
we already knew that we're
looking at games that only have
three possible outcomes win,
loss, or tie so it doesn't seem
so surprising if you look at
this theorem,
it says,
well, you're going to end up
with a win, or a loss,
or a tie.
However, that's not quite what
the theorem says.
The theorem says,
not only are you going to end
up there--we knew that
already--but the games divide
themselves.
Games of these forms divide
themselves into those games in
which Player 1 has a way of
winning regardless of what
Player 2 does;
or games in which Player 1 has
a way of forcing a tie
regardless of what Player 2
does;
or Player 2 has a way of
winning regardless of what
Player 1 does,
so these games all have a
solution.
Let's just go back to Nim to
illustrate the point.
So in Nim actually there's no
tie so we can forget the middle
of these, and in Nim,
under certain circumstances it
is the case that Player 1 can
force a win.
Who remembers what the case
was, for when Player 1 can force
a win?
Anybody?
The people who played last time.
No, yes, Ale,
there's somebody here.
Shout it out.
Student: Insuring that
the piles are equal for the
other player.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so if the piles start
unequal, then Player 1 can
actually force a win.
So in Nim if the piles are
unequal at the start,
then 1 can force a win.
It really doesn't matter what 2
does, 2 is "toast."
Or the alternative case is the
piles are equal at the start,
and if they're equal at the
start then it's Player 1 who's
"toast."
Player 2 is going
to--rather--force a loss on 1,
so 2 can force a loss on 1,
i.e.
a win for Player 2.
Does everyone remember that
from last time?
It's just before the weekend,
it shouldn't be so long ago.
So this theorem applies to all
games of this form.
So what games are of this form?
Let's try and think of some
other examples.
So one example is tic-tac-toe.
Everyone know the rules of
tic-tac-toe?
In England we call it Noughts
and Crosses, but you guys call
it tic-tac-toe,
is that right?
Everyone know what tic-tac-toe
is?
Yeah, which category is
tic-tac-toe?
Is it a game which Player 1 can
force a win, or is it a category
in which Player 1 can only force
a tie,
or is it a category which you'd
rather go second and Player 2
can force a win for Player 2 or
a loss for Player 1?
Which is tic-tac-toe?
Let's have a show of hands here.
Who thinks tic-tac-toe is a
game in which Player 1 can force
a win?
Who thinks tic-tac-toe is a
game in which Player 1 can only
force a tie?
Who thinks Player 2's going to
win?
Most of you are right.
It's a game in which if people
play correctly then it'll turn
out to be a tie.
So tic-tac-toe is a game that
leads to a tie.
Player 1 can still make a
mistake, in which case they can
lose.
Player 2 can make a mistake in
which case they would lose,
but there is a way of playing
that forces a tie.
So these are fairly simple
games, let's talk about more
complicated games.
So what about the game of
checkers?
So the game of checkers meets
these conditions.
It's a two player game.
You always know all the moves
prior to your move.
It's finite:
there's some rules in checkers
that prevent it going on
forever.
And there are two or three
outcomes: I guess there's a
third outcome if you get into a
cycle you could tie.
So checkers fits all these
descriptions and what this
theorem tells us is that
checkers has a solution.
I'm not sure I know what that
solution is, or I think actually
somebody did compute it quite
recently,
even in the last few months,
I just forgot to Google it this
morning to remind myself.
But what this theorem tells us
even before those people that
computed it: checkers has a
solution.
Let's be a bit more ambitious.
What about chess?
So chess meets this description.
Chess is a two player game,
everybody knows all the moves
before them, it's sequential,
it has finite number of moves,
it's a very large number but it
is finite, and it has three
possible outcomes,
a win, a loss, or a tie.
So let's be careful,
the reason it's finite is that
if you cycle--I forget what it
is--three times then the game is
declared a draw,
declared a tie.
So what's this theorem telling
us?
It's telling us that there is a
way to solve chess.
Chess has a solution.
We don't know what that
solution is.
It could be that solution is
that Player 1,
who's the player with the white
pieces can force a win.
It could be that Player 1 can
only force a tie,
and it could even be that
Player 2 can force a win.
We don't know which it is,
but there is a solution.
There's a catch to this theorem.
What's the catch?
The catch is it doesn't
actually tell us--this theorem
is not going to tell us what
that solution is.
It doesn't tell us how to play.
This theorem,
in and of itself,
doesn't tell us how to play
chess.
It just says there is a
way to play chess.
So we're going to try and prove
this.
We don't often do proofs in
class, but the reason I want to
prove this particular one is
because I think the proof is
instructive as part of sort of
QR at Yale.
So here's another example here,
and some other examples.
You could think of chess as
being the most dramatic example.
So the reason I want to spend
actually some time proving this
today is because we're going to
prove it by induction and I'm
going to sketch the proof.
I'm not going to go through
every possible step but I want
to give people here a feeling
for what a proof by induction
looks like.
The reason for this is,
my guess is,
well let's find out,
how many of you have seen a
proof by induction before?
How many have not?
So for those of you who haven't
I think it's a good thing in
life, at one point in your life
to see a proof by induction,
and for those who have,
my guess is you saw it in some
awful math class in high school
and it just went over--it didn't
necessarily go over your head
but,
the excitement of it doesn't
catch on.
This is a context where it
might appeal.
So proof by induction.
We're going to prove this by
induction on the maximum length
of the game and we'll call that
N.
We'll call N the maximum length
of the game.
What do I mean by this?
If I write down a tree I can
always look at all the paths
from the beginning of the tree
all the way through to the end
of the tree.
And I'm going to look at the
path in that particular tree
that has the largest length,
and I'll call that the length
of the game, the maximum length
of the game.
So we're going to do induction
on the maximum length of the
game.
So how do we start a proof by
induction?
Let's just remind ourselves,
those people who have seen them
before.
We're going to prove that this
theorem this true,
the claim in the theorem is
true for the easy case when the
game is only 1 move long.
That's the first step,
and then we're going to try and
show that if it's true for all
games of length <
= N,
whatever N is,
then it must therefore be true
for games of length N+1.
That's the way you do a proof
by induction.
So let's just see how that
works in practice.
So let's start with the easy
step and we'll do it in some
detail, more detail than you
really need to in a math class.
So if N = 1,
what do these games look like?
Well let's look at some
examples here.
So I claim it's pretty trivial
if N = 1 but let's do it anyway.
So the game might look like
this.
Player 1 is going to
move--here's Player 1
moving--the game's only length
one--so Player 1's the only
player who ever gets to move.
So the game might look like
this.
Let's put in a fifth branch,
it might look like this.
And at the end of this game,
rather than putting payoffs let
me just put the outcomes.
So the outcome must either be a
win, or a tie,
or a loss, so suppose it looks
like this.
Suppose it's a win,
or here we could have a tie,
or here we could have a win
again, or here we could have a
loss, and here we could have a
tie.
So in this particular game I
claim it's pretty clear this
game has a solution.
It's pretty clear what 1 should
do.
What should 1 do?
1 should pick one of her
choices that leads to a win.
To be careful I'll put 1 in
here just to distinguish who it
is who's actually winning and
losing.
So in this game I claim that
this game has a pretty obvious
solution, either Player 1 is
going to choose this branch that
leads to a win or this branch
that leads to a win,
and either way Player 1 is
going to win.
Is that obvious?
It's so obvious,
it's kind of painful.
So I claim this game,
we could actually replace this
first node with what's going to
happen which is Player 1's going
to win.
Is that right?
That was easy.
Let's look at a different
example, we'll do three.
So here's another possible
example, and this again,
Player 1 is going to move here
and this time the possible
outcomes are tie,
or a loss, or a loss.
Once again it's a one player
game, this time he has three
choices and the three choices
lead to a tie or he loses,
so I claim once again this is
simple.
What Player 1 should do is what?
Choose the tie since there's no
way of winning.
But in that case he could
actually force it.
He could actually choose the
tie in which case he's going to
tie.
So this game has a solution
called choose the tie.
And again, we could replace the
first node of the game with
what's actually going to happen
which is a tie.
Everyone happy?
There's one other possibility I
guess.
The other possibility is that
here Player 1 has a lot of
choices, maybe four choices in
this case,
once again Player 1 is going to
move but in each
case--unfortunately for Player
1--in each case the outcome is
that Player 1 loses.
So this is a game in which
Player 1 is going to lose no
matter what they do.
Once again it has a solution:
the solution is Player 1 is
toast and is going to lose.
So I claim this has really
captured all the possibilities
of games of length 1.
I mean you could imagine that
there could be more branches on
them, but basically there are
these three possibilities.
Either it's the case that one
of those branches leads to a
win, in which case the solution
is Player 1 wins;
or it's the case that none of
the branches have wins in them,
but one of them has a tie,
in which Player 1 is going to
tie;
or it's the case that all the
branches have loss in them,
in which Player 1's going to
lose.
So I claim I'm for done for
games of length one.
Everyone okay?
So that step is deceptively
easy but there it is.
All right, now we do the
inductive step,
the big step.
What we're going to do is we're
going to assume that the
statement of the theorem,
which I've now hidden
unfortunately--let me unhide it
if I can, it's not going to be
easy.
This now visible?
So now let's assume that the
statement of this theorem is
true for all games length <
= N, suppose that's the case.
Suppose the claim is true for
all games of this type,
of length <= some N.
What we need to show is--what
we're going to try and show is
therefore it will be true for
all games of length N + 1.
What we want to show is--we
claim, therefore,
it will be true for games of
length N + 1,
that's the key step in
inductive proofs.
All right, so how are we going
to do that?
Well let's have a look at a
game of length N + 1,
and obviously I can't use
thousands here so let me choose
from relatively small numbers,
but the idea will go through.
So let's have a look at a game.
So here's a game in which
Player 1 moves first,
Player 2 moves second.
Let's suppose that if Player 2
does this, then 1 only has
little choice here,
up here then one has a more
complicated choice,
and perhaps 2 could move again.
So this is quite a complicated
little game up here,
and down here let's make it a
little bit less complicated.
Here the game looks like this
and then comes to an end,
so the tree looks like this.
I haven't put the end,
I haven't put the outcomes on
it but the tree looks like this.
So how long is this tree first
of all?
Well I claim that the longest
path in this tree,
from the beginning to the end
has four steps.
Let's just check.
So one, two,
three, four that's what I claim
is the longest path.
Any path going down this way
only has three moves in it,
so this is a game of length
four.
So we can apply it to our
claim, let's assume that the
theorem holds for all trees
length three or fewer,
so that N + 1 is 4 for the
purpose of our example.
So in this example--I don't
want to put it here,
let's put it here--in this
example N = 3,
so that N + 1 = 4.
Everyone happy with this in the
example?
Now what I want to observe
about this is the following:
contained in this N + 1,
or the game of length 4 are
some smaller games.
You could think of them as
sub-games.
They're games within the game,
is that right?
So let's have a look.
I claim, in particular--draw
around them in pink--there's a
game here that follows Player 1
choosing Up and there's a game
here that follows Player 1
choosing Down,
is that right?
Okay, so these are both games,
and what do we have here?
So this little game in
here--the game in the top
circle, the game that follows
Player 1 moving up--that's a
game and it has a length.
So this little thing is a game
and I'm going to call it a
sub-game, some jargon that we'll
be getting used to later on in
the semester.
It's a game within the game,
but it's basically just a game:
it's a sub-game and this is a
sub-game following 1 choosing
Up--let's put Up in
here--following up.
And I claim that this game has
a length--this sub-game has a
length.
So we knew that we started from
a game of length 4,
we've taken one of the moves,
and let's just make sure this
is actually a game of length 3.
So the game started here,
this would be a game of length
3 because you could go one,
two, three moves,
is that right?
So this is a game of length 3.
So this is a sub-game following
1 choosing Up and it,
the sub-game,
has length 3.
Down here, this is also a
sub-game, it's a game that
follows Player 1 choosing Down
and this little sub-game has
length--now here we have to be a
little bit careful--you might
think that since we started from
a game of length 4,
after the first move we must be
in a game of length 3.
But actually that's not true,
and if we look carefully,
we'll notice that this game
down here, the game starting
here actually isn't of length 3.
It's of length 2.
Is that right?
So even though started from a
game of length 4,
by going this way we put
ourselves into a game of length
2.
Is that right?
So 1,2 or 1,2--whatever--it has
length 2.
Okay, all right so in this
example N is 3 and N + 1 is 4,
and our assumption,
our induction assumption is
what?
We've assumed that the claim of
the theorem holds for all games
<= N, which in this case
means <= 3.
So what does that tell us?
That tells us,
by our assumption,
this game, which I've put a
pink circle around on the top,
this is a game of length 3,
this game has a solution.
It must have a solution because
it's of length 3 or less.
So by the induction hypothesis
as it's called--by the induction
hypothesis--this is a technical
term, but what's the induction
hypothesis?
It's this thing.
By the assumption that we made
this game has a solution.
So it's a game of length 3,3
<= N in this case.
So this game must have a
solution.
Now I don't immediately know by
staring at it what it is,
but let's suppose it was W,
say it was W.
And the game down below,
this is also a game,
and it's a game of length 2 but
2 is less than 3 as well,
2 <= 3.
So this game also has a
solution.
This game also,
by the same assumption,
has a solution,
so its solution is say--I don't
know--maybe its L.
So what does that mean to say
that these games have solutions,
in this case we're going to
assume W is this one,
and L is this one,
what does it mean?
It means that,
just as we did with the games
up there, we could put the
solution at the beginning of the
game.
We know that if we get into
this game, we're going to get
the solution of this game;
and we know if we get into this
game, we're going to get the
solution of this game.
So we can replace this one with
its solution which by assumption
was W, and this one by its
solution which by assumption was
L.
And here I want to be really
careful, I need to keep track of
which person it is it's a win or
loss for.
So this was a win for Player 1,
hence it was a loss for Player
2, and this was a loss for
Player 1, hence it was a win for
Player 2.
So these games,
each of them have some
solution, and this case I've
written down the solutions as W
or L.
So now what could we do?
Let me just bring down this
board again.
I can translate this game into
a very simple game.
I'm going to translate it up
here, so this game can be
translated as follows.
Player 1 moves,
if he goes Up then he hits a W
and if he goes Down he hits a L.
So in this particular example,
Player 1 is effectively
choosing between going Up and
finding himself in a game which
has a solution,
and the solution is he wins it,
or going Down and finding
himself in a game which has a
solution,
and the solution is he's toast.
But that's what?
That's a one move game.
So we know this has a solution,
and in particular,
he's going to choose Up.
This one has a solution.
This has a solution,
it is a game of length 1.
So what do we do?
Somewhat schematically,
we took a game of length N + 1,
in this case that was 4;
and we pointed out that once
Player 1 has made her first move
in this game,
we are in a game,
or in a sub-game if you like,
that has length less than 4,
it could be 3,
it could be 2,
whatever.
Whatever sub-game we're in,
by assumption,
that game has a solution.
So it's really effectively,
Player 1 is choosing between
going into a game with solution
W or going into a game with
solution L.
And if there were 15 other
sub-games here,
each one would have a solution,
and each one Player 1 would be
able to associate that solution
with what he's going to
get--what she's going to get.
So I claim that,
if it in fact is true that each
of these sub-games of length 3
or less had a solution,
then the game of length 4 must
have a solution,
which is what?
It's the solution which is:
Player 1 should pick the best
sub-game.
Are people convinced by that
step?
People are looking slightly
"deer in the headlamps" now,
so let me just say it again.
We started by assuming that all
games of length 3 or less,
or N or less,
have a solution.
We pointed out that any game
that has length N + 1 can be
thought of as an initial move by
Player 1 followed by a game of
length N or less,
N or fewer I should say.
Each of those games of N or
fewer steps has a solution,
so Player 1 is just going to
choose the game that has the
best solution for her and we're
done.
In this particular example,
Player 1 is going to choose Up
and therefore the solution to
this parent game is Player 1
wins.
Now the hard step I think in
proofs by induction is realizing
that you're done.
So I claim we're now done,
why are we done?
Well we know that it was pretty
easy that all games of length 1
have a solution.
That was pretty trivial.
And we've shown that if any
game of length of N or fewer has
a solution, then games of N + 1
have a solution.
So now let's see how we can
proceed.
We know that games of length 1
have a solution,
so let's consider games of
length 2.
Games of length 2,
do games of length 2 have a
solution?
Well let's set N = 1.
We know that if games of length
1 have a solution,
then any game of length 2 could
be thought of as an initial step
followed by a game of length 1,
but that has a solution,
so therefore games of length 2
have a solution.
Now let's think of games with
length 3, we've shown that games
with length 1 have a solution
and games with length 2 have a
solution.
Any game of length 3 can be
thought of as a game in which
there's an initial step followed
by either a game of length 1 or
a game of length 2,
each of which have a solution,
so once again a game of length
3 has a solution and so on.
So games of induction,
they work by building up on the
length of the game,
and we're ending up knowing
that we're done.
For those people who have never
seen a proof by induction don't
worry I'm not going to test you
on a proof with induction on the
exam,
I just wanted you to see one
once.
Let's all take a deep breath
and try and digest this a little
bit by playing a game.
I'll leave it up there so you
can stare at it.
We'll want it down again later.
Let's try and actually play a
game and see if we can actually
throw any light on this.
So I'm going to pick out
volunteers like I did last time,
but first of all,
let me tell you what the game
is.
So once again I'm going to have
rocks in this game,
and once again I'm going to
approximate those rocks with
marks on the blackboard.
So here's an example.
The example is this.
The game involves an array of
rocks, so here the array has
five rows and three columns.
So the rocks are not arranged
as they were before in piles,
but rather in a sort of in a
pretty array.
I should have made it more even
but this is: one,
two, three, four,
five rows;
and one, two,
three columns,
at least in this example.
But in general there's an array
of rocks, N x M.
We're going to play
sequentially with the players.
And the way the game is going
to work is this--is when it's
your turn to move,
you have to point to one of
these rocks and whichever rock
you point to I will remove.
I will delete that rock and all
the rocks that lie above or to
the right of it:
all the rocks that lie to the
northeast of it.
So for example,
if you pointed to this rock,
then I will remove this rock
and also this one,
this one, and this one.
If the next person comes along
and chooses this one,
then I will remove this one,
and also that one.
Okay, everyone understand?
All right and the game is
lost--this is important--the
game is lost by the person who
ends up taking the last rock.
The loser is the person who
ends up removing the last rock.
Could I have some volunteers?
Can I volunteer people then?
How about the guy with the
white t-shirt with the yellow on
there?
Okay, come on up front,
and who else can I volunteer.
Everyone's looking away from
me, desperately looking away
from me.
How about the guy with the Yale
sweatshirt on,
the Yale football sweatshirt
on, okay.
So come on up.
Your name is?
I should get a mike,
let me get a mike up here,
thank you.
Great, your name is?
Student: Noah.
Professor Ben Polak:
Noah and your name is?
Student: Koran.
Professor Ben Polak:Say
it into the mike.
Student: Koran.
Professor Ben Polak:
Koran okay.
So Noah and Koran are our
players.
Everyone understand the rules?
Do you understand the rules?
Yeah?
So why don't we make Noah go
first.
So Noah which rock are you
going to remove?
Remember the last rock loses.
Student: That one.
Professor Ben Polak:
That one.
Okay, so Noah chose this one.
So I'm going to remove this one
and the one above it.
Student: So all the
rocks to the north and east are
deleted, right?
Professor Ben Polak: All
the rocks to the north and east
of it are deleted.
That means you--last rock loses.
Okay good.
Student: That one.
Professor Ben Polak:
That one okay.
So now we have an L shape.
Student: That one.
Professor Ben Polak:
That one, all right.
Student: That one.
Professor Ben Polak:
That one okay,
okay.
All right so we're done.
Okay, everyone understand how
that worked?
Round of applause for our
players please,
thank you.
Let me get two more volunteers
now that everyone has seen it.
These guys had the hard job,
they had to figure it out cold.
Two more volunteers?
Oh I don't have to pick
volunteers--this is Yale,
somebody volunteer.
Are you volunteering?
Great.
I have one volunteer.
You can pick an opponent if you
like.
There you go thank you.
Your name is,
let's just wait until the mikes
are here.
So your name is?
Student: Peter.
Professor Ben Polak:
Peter and your name is Justin.
Student: Justin.
Professor Ben Polak: Let
me put a new array up here.
So let's put a new array up
here and this time let's make
it--it doesn't have to be odd.
So let's make it this time a
little bit more complicated.
So we'll have five--let's have
four rows and five columns this
time.
Okay so last time I had five
rows and three columns,
and this time I have four rows
and five columns.
Away you go,
let me move out of the way.
Why don't you stand a bit
nearer to the board--make it a
little easier for people to see
what's going on,
there you go.
So Peter you want to go first?
Student: Sure, that one.
Professor Ben Polak:
That one okay.
So this one goes,
which means all of these go as
well.
Anyone got any advice from the
floor?
Shout things out, not too loud.
Student: I'll try going
here.
Professor Ben Polak:
There.
Okay we're back to our L shape
again here.
Now people can see what's going
on all right.
Student: I'll go here
and speed it up.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right thank you.
So a round of applause again.
Thank you guys.
So here's what I claim about
this game.
First, and this isn't a formal
claim, this is a lot harder than
the game we played last time,
right?
Everyone is convinced by that
all right.
So here's going to be an
exercise, or something that's a
challenge.
I may even put it formally on
the problem set this week,
but let me just say if I do put
this on the problem set this
week,
I don't expect you all to solve
it.
So if I do put it on the
problem set, it's an optional
problem.
But here's the challenge,
the challenge is,
I know from Zermelo's theorem
that no matter what N is,
and no matter what M is,
this game has a solution.
So Zermelo's theorem tells us
Now, notice it could have a
different solution depending on
the N and the M,
depending on how many rows and
how many columns,
is that right?.
So depending on N and M,
each such game has a
solution--is that right--which
could depend on N and on M,
on the number of rows and
columns.
So just as in Nim,
it depended on how those piles
started out.
So what's going to be the
homework assignment?
Find the solution.
Homework- what is the solution?
So I claim, let me give you a
hint, I claim it is useful to
remember that there is a
solution.
It turns out to be useful to
remember that.
That wasn't much of a hint.
You knew that already,
but let me just emphasize that.
Okay, so I want to do a bit of
a transition now away from these
games like chess and like
checkers,
and like this game with the
rocks or Nim,
and I want to be a little bit
formal for a while.
So one thing that we haven't
done for a while,
actually since the mid-term,
is write down some formal
definitions.
So I'm going to do that now.
I want at least one of these
boards back.
So as I warned very early in
the class, there are some points
of the day when we have to stop
and do some work and the next
twenty minutes or so is such a
point.
So what is this?
This is formal stuff.
The first thing I want to do is
I want to give you a formal
definition of something I've
already mentioned today and
that's the idea of perfect
information.
What we've been looking at,
or at least since the mid-term,
are games of perfect
information.
So a game of perfect
information is one in which at
every node, or at each node in
the game the player whose turn
it is to move at that node knows
which node she is at.
So it's a very simple idea.
Every game we've seen since the
mid-term has this property.
When you're playing this game
you know where you are.
So you know which node you're
at, you know what your choices
are and what that means
implicitly is she must know how
she got there.
So the whole history of the
game is observed by everybody.
When I get to move I know what
you did yesterday,
I know what I did the day
before yesterday,
and if I'm playing with a third
person I know what they did the
day before that.
So a very simple idea but it
turns out to be an idea that
actually allows us to use things
like backward induction very
simply.
Now so far all we've been doing
is thinking about such games,
games like perfect competition,
sorry games like quantity
competition between firms or
games like the games where we
were setting up incentives or
games like Nim,
and we've basically been
solving these games by backward
induction, rather informally.
What I want to add in now is
the notion of a strategy in
these games.
So when we had simultaneous
move games, strategies were
really unproblematic.
It was obvious what strategies
were.
But when we have games which
are sequential,
that go on over a period of
time,
and information is emerging
over a period of time,
we need to be a little careful
what we mean by a strategy.
So what I want to do is I want
to define a pure strategy at
least as follows.
So a pure strategy for Player i
in a game of perfect
information--so in the games
we've been talking about,
games which we can represent by
trees is what?
It's a complete plan of action.
So in other words,
what it does is it specifies
which action I should
take--let's not make it should
take--let's say will
take,
at each of i's nodes,
each of i's decision nodes.
So when you first read this
definition it seems completely
uninteresting and unproblematic.
A pure strategy for Player i
just tells you in this game
whenever you might be called
upon to move,
it tells you how you're going
to move.
So if you're going to move
three times in the game,
it tells you how you're going
to move the first time;
to move the second time;
and it tells you how you're
going to move the third time.
So, so far none of this seems
difficult but actually it's a
bit more difficult than it
looks.
So let's have a look.
What I want to do is I want to
look at an example,
and this example I'm hoping is
going to illustrate some
subtleties about this
definition.
So here's an example.
In this example Player 1 moves
first and they can choose in or
out, or if you like let's call
it up or down since that's the
way we've drawn it.
So they can choose down or
up--and I'll use capital letters
U and D.
If Player chooses U then Player
2 gets to move and Player 2 can
choose L or R.
If Player 1 moves U followed by
Player 2 choosing L,
then Player 1 gets to move,
in which case Player 1 could
move up or down and I'll use
little letters this time,
u and d.
Let's put some payoffs in this
game.
So the payoffs are 1,0 here,
0,2 here, 3,1 here and 2,4
here.
So on paper--it's on the
board--when you first look at
it, this is a perfectly simple
game.
It's just like many of the
games we've been looking at
since the mid-term.
It has a tree.
We could analyze it by backward
induction, and in a moment we
will analyze it by backward
induction.
But what I want to do first is
I want to say what are the
strategies in this game?
So let's start with Player 2
since it's easier.
Player 2's strategies here are
what?
Pretty simple:
player 2 only has one decision
node--here's Player 2's decision
node--and the strategy has to
tell Player 2 what he's going to
do at that decision node.
So there's only two choices,
L or R.
So Player 2's strategies are
either L or R.
Notice, however,
already one slight subtlety
here.
Player 2 may never get to make
this choice.
So Player 2 is choosing L or R,
but Player 2 may not ever get
to make this choice.
In particular,
if 1 chose D it's really
irrelevant whether Player 2 has
chosen L or R.
Nevertheless,
the strategy has to specify
what Player 2 would do were he
called upon to make that move.
Now let's look at Player 1's
strategies.
So what are Player 1's
strategies in this game?
Any takers?
Anyone want to guess?
So I claim it's tempting,
but it turns out to be wrong,
to say that Player 1 has three
strategies here.
It's tempting to say either
Player 1 moves D,
in which case we're done,
or Player 1 moves U,
in which case at some later
date she may be called upon to
choose u or d again.
So it's very tempting to think
that Player 1 has just three
strategies here,
D in which case we're done,
or U followed by either u or d,
if she's reached that point.
But actually,
if we follow this definition
carefully, we notice that Player
1 actually has four strategies
here.
So let me say what they are and
you'll see why it's a little
odd.
So here's one of the strategies
we talked about,
U followed by u,
and here's another one we
talked about,
U followed by d,
but I claim there are two
others, D followed by u and D
followed by d.
So what's a little weird about
this?
What's weird is we know
perfectly well that if Player 1
chooses D she's not going to get
to make the choice,
the second choice u or d.
But nevertheless the strategy
has to tell us what she would do
at every node,
regardless of whether that node
actually is reached by that
strategy.
Let me say it again,
the strategy has to tell you
what Player 1 would do at that
node,
regardless of whether that node
is actually reached by playing
that strategy.
So a little weird.
There's a bit of redundancy
here.
It's a bit redundant.
Now why?
Well we'll see why in a second.
Let's first of all consider how
this game will be played
according to backward induction.
So how do we play this game
according to backward induction?
Where do we start?
Shouldn't be a trick question,
where do we start the game
according to backward induction?
At the end okay.
So the end here is Player 1 and
Player 1 will choose here to go
d, is that right?
Because 3 is bigger than 2.
So if we roll back to Player
2's move, Player 2 if she
chooses L she knows that she'll
be followed by Player 1 going d,
in which case she'll get 1,
but if she chooses R she'll get
2.
So Player 2 will choose R.
So Player 1 here,
if she chooses U then Player 2
will choose R and Player 1 will
get 0, and if she chooses D
she'll get 1,
so Player 1 will choose D.
So, backward induction suggests
that Player 1 will choose D;
and followed by Player 2--if
Player 2 did get to move--she'd
choose R;
followed by Player 1--if she
did get to move again--choosing
d again.
Notice that backward induction
had to tell us what Player 2
would have done had she got to
move.
Backward induction had to
consider what Player 2 would
think that Player 1 would have
done were Player 1 to get to
move again.
So to do backward induction,
Player 1 has to ask herself
what Player 2 is going to do;
and Player 2 has to therefore
ask herself what Player 1 would
have done;
which means Player 1 has to ask
herself what Player 2 thinks
Player 1 would have done;
which means we actually needed
to say what Player 1 did over
here.
Let me say that again.
So backward induction here
tells us that Player 1 chooses D
in which case the game is over.
But to do backward induction,
to think through backward
induction, we really needed to
consider not just what Player 2
was going to do were he to get
to move,
but also what Player 2 would
think Player 1 would do were
Player 2 to get to move and were
to do choose L.
So all of these redundant moves
were actually part of our
backward induction.
We need them there so we can
think about what people are
thinking.
So backward induction tells us
that the outcome of the game is
D, but it tells in terms of
strategies,
Player 1 chooses D and,
were she to get to move again,
would choose D again.
And Player 2 chooses R.
Now let's analyze this game a
totally different way.
We now know what the strategies
are in the game:
Player 2 has two strategies,
L and R;
and Player 1 has four
strategies: U/u,
U/d, D/u and D/d.
So let's write up the matrix
for this game,
so here it is.
It must be a 4 x 2 matrix,
Player 2 is choosing between L
and R and Player 1 is choosing
between her four strategies Uu,
Ud, Du and Dd and we can put
all the payoffs in.
So (Uu,L) gets us here which is
(2,4).
(Uu,R) gets us here which is
(0,2).
(Ud,L) gets us here which is
(3,1).
(Ud,R) gets us here again which
is (0,2).
And Du gets us,
going right out of the game
immediately, so we're going to
go to (1,0).
And in fact that's also true
for (Du,R), and it's also true
for (Dd,L) and it's also true
for (D/d,R).
So all of these four strategies
at the bottom started off by
Player 1 choosing D,
in which case the game is over.
So once again in this matrix
you can kind of see the
redundancy I was talking about.
In this matrix,
the third row,
the Du row looks the same as
the Dd row.
Everyone happy with that?
So when we've had matrices in
the past how have we solved the
game?
Well we've been doing this
backward induction stuff for a
couple of weeks,
but,
prior to the mid-term--if I had
given you this on the mid-term
what would you have done?
You'd look for a Nash
Equilibrium right?
So let's do that:
let's look for Nash
Equilibrium.
So if Player 2 chooses L then
Player 1's best response is Uu;
and if Player 2 chooses R,
then Player 1's best response
is either Du or Dd.
Conversely, if Player 1 chooses
Uu then Player 2's best response
is L.
If Player 1 chooses Ud then
Player 2's best response is R.
If Player 1 chooses Du then
Player 2 doesn't care because
they're getting 0 anyway;
and if Player 1 chooses Dd then
again Player 2 doesn't care
because they're getting 0
anyway.
So the Nash Equilibria in this
game are what?
So one of them is here,
so that's one Nash Equilibrium.
One of them is Dd followed by
R, and that's a Nash Equilibrium
we actually found by backward
induction.
The Nash Equilibrium (Dd,R)
corresponds to the one we found
by backward induction.
But there's another Nash
Equilibrium in this game.
The other Nash Equilibrium in
this game is this one.
That's also a Nash Equilibrium.
What does it involve?
It involves Du and R--sorry Du
and R.
So what happened in that
equilibrium?
Player 1 went down which made
everything else kind of
irrelevant.
Player 2 played R and Player 1
in their plan of action was
actually going to choose u.
Say it again,
Player 1 in fact went D,
Player 2 had they got to move
would have chosen R and Player 1
had they got to move at this
second time would have chosen u.
So how can that be a Nash
Equilibrium?
It doesn't correspond to
backward induction.
In particular,
Player 1 up here is choosing a
strategy that seems silly.
They're choosing u rather than
d which gets them 2 rather than
3.
So how could it possibly be
that that's an equilibrium
strategy?
The reason is--the reason it
can be an equilibrium strategy
is it doesn't really matter what
Player 1 chooses up here from
Player 1's point of view because
it's never going to be reached
anyway.
As long as Player 2 is going to
choose R here,
it really doesn't matter what
Player 1 decides to do up there.
From Player 1's point of view,
it doesn't make a difference.
It isn't reached anyway.
So we're highlighting here a
danger, and the danger is this.
If you just mechanically find
the Nash Equilibria in a game,
you're going to find people
choosing actions that,
if they ever were called upon
to make them,
are silly.
Say it again,
if you just mechanically find
the Nash Equilibria in the game,
just as we did here,
you're going to select some
actions, in this case an action
by Player 1,
that were she called upon to
take that action would be a
silly action.
The reason it's surviving our
analysis is because in fact she
isn't called upon to make it.
Now to make that more concrete,
let's take this to an economic
example, this same idea.
So what I want you to imagine
is a market, and in this market
there is a monopolist who
controls the market,
but there's an entrant who is
thinking of entering into this
market.
So right now this market has a
monopoly in it,
and the monopolist is an
incumbent--let's call him
Inc--and an entrant who is
trying to decide whether or not
to enter the market or whether
to stay out.
If they stay out then the
entrant gets nothing and the
incumbent continues to get
monopoly profits.
So think of this as 3 million a
year.
If the entrant enters then the
incumbent can do one of two
things.
The incumbent could choose to
fight the entrant,
by which I mean charge low
prices, advertise a lot,
try and drive him out of the
market.
He could play very
competitively,
in which case the entrant will
actually make losses,
and the incumbent will drive
her profits down to zero.
Conversely, the incumbent could
choose not to fight.
If they don't fight then
they'll simply share the market
and they'll both make,
let's say Cournot profits or
duopoly profits of a million
each.
So in this game,
let's just say again,
there's a market there.
The monopolist is in the market
and the monopolist is making 3
million a year which seems
pretty nice for the monopolist.
The entrant is trying to decide
whether to invade this market.
If she invades this market,
if she's fought she's in
trouble, but if the monopolist
accommodates her,
then they just go to duopoly
profits and the entrant does
very well, gets a million
dollars in profit.
Let's have a look at this game.
Analyze--first of all this
time, let's analyze it by Nash
Equilibrium.
So I claim in this game,
this is pretty simple:
the entrant has two strategies.
I'll put it straight into the
matrix.
The entrant has two strategies,
they're either to go in or to
stay out;
and the incumbent has two
strategies, they are either to
fight the entrant or not to
fight.
The payoffs of this game are as
follows--let's put them in.
In and fight was (-1,0),
in and not fight was (1,1) and
out led to the incumbents
maintaining the monopoly
profits.
Let's have a look at the Nash
Equilibria of this game.
So the first thing to do is to
look at the best responses for
the entrant.
So if the incumbent chooses
fight, then the entrant's best
response is to stay out.
If the incumbent chooses not
fight, then the entrant's best
response is to enter.
How about for the incumbent?
If the entrant chooses to come
in then the incumbent's best
response is not to fight because
1 is bigger than 0.
But if the entrant stays out it
really doesn't matter what the
incumbent does,
they'll get 3 either way.
So the Nash Equilibria here are
either in followed by not
fighting, you end up with a
duopoly, or out followed by
fighting.
Of course the fight doesn't
take place: out followed by "we
would have fought had you
entered."
So these are the Nash
Equilibria.
Let's analyze this game by
backward induction.
From the incumbent's point of
view, if the incumbent gets to
move then is she going to choose
fight or not fight?
She's going to choose not
fight, so the entrant should do
what?
Somebody?
The entrant should enter,
because if she enters she gets
1, if she stays out she gets 0.
So backward induction just
gives us this equilibrium.
Now the question is what do we
think is going on with this
other equilibrium?
Let's talk it through.
So here you are,
you're about to enter the
market, you leave Yale,
you set up your business,
and your business is
challenging some monopolist or
quasi-monopolist like Microsoft
say.,
And you go out there and you're
about to put out your new
operating system.
And you know that your new
operating system will make
plenty of money provided
Microsoft doesn't retaliate and
drop its prices by half and
advertise you out of the market.
So what does Bill Gates do?
Bill Gates is the head of
Microsoft.
He says, wait a second before
you graduate from Yale and go
set up this company,
let me just tell you I'm going
to fight.
If you enter I'm going to fight.
And if you believe him,
if you believe that he's going
to fight, what should you do?
You're not going to bother to
enter his market.
And if you believe that you're
going to get fought by Bill
Gates then you believe that if
you enter you're going to make
losses,
so you choose to stay out.
And this threat that Bill Gates
makes here it doesn't cost him
anything, provided you go out,
he doesn't actually have to
fight at all.
That's why it is in fact an
equilibrium to imagine you
staying out believing that
you're going to get fought if
you enter,
and it is a best response for
the guy to fight knowing that
you're going to stay out.
But this doesn't sound right.
Why doesn't this sound right?
It doesn't sound right because
you really shouldn't believe the
guy who says he's going to fight
you when you know that if you
did enter fighting would cost
the incumbent money.
If you did enter,
if he fights you he gets 0,
if he doesn't fight he gets a
million dollars.
So this threat that the guy is
going to fight you,
this threat is not credible.
This is an equilibrium but it
relies on believing an
incredible threat.
It's true that if you think
about entering the market that
Microsoft is in,
you're very likely to get a
little email from Bill Gates.
(But it won't be an email
because that can be taken to
Court, but some little
threatening remark in your ear
from Bill Gates.) It's true if
you entered into the market that
the people who build aircraft
in,
the head of Boeing might pay
you a call one day or send
someone round,
but these threats are not
credible threats.
Is that right?
They're not credible threats
because we know that if you did
enter, it isn't in their
interest to fight.
They're making a lot of noise
about it but you know that if
you did enter,
backward induction tells us
they're not going to fight.
But now we're in slightly an
odd situation,
why are we in an odd situation?
Two things.
One, we seem to be finding that
there are Nash Equilibria in
games--we found one here and one
up here--there are Nash
Equilibria that are not
supported by backward induction.
That's the first reason we're a
little worried here,
and the second reason we're
worried is even the economics of
this doesn't quite smell right.
For example,
if you in fact did
enter--sorry,
if you did in fact announce you
were going to operate,
you were going to build a new
operating system and got a
threatening phone call from Bill
Gates--there might be a reason
why you might actually believe
that call.
Why might you believe that call?
Can we get a mike out,
I'll do it.
So why might you believe a call
from Bill Gates saying he's
going to beat you up--not beat
you up but he's going to charge
low prices if you produce an
operating system?
Student: If you look at
the future revenue streams,
like for the next ten years and
he consistently gets 1 million
dollars for the next ten years,
he would be better off if he
just drove you out of the market
for the first year and then get
3 million dollars for the next
nine years.
Professor Ben Polak:
That wasn't quite what I wasn't
thinking of.
Okay, it's true if we cheat a
bit and make one of the--Okay,
so what you're saying is I
could get 3 forever versus 1
forever,
assume these are both present
discounted values of future cash
earnings.
So we've done the future cash
flow analysis of this.
So this isn't an accounting
mistake, not for accounting
reasons.
There's some other reason when
Gates threatens you,
you might want to believe it.
Let's try up here first.
Student: He can afford
to make an example of you so no
other people will invade.
Professor Ben Polak:
Right, so one thing that's in
Bill Gates' mind is right now,
he's thinking about competing
with you but down the road
there's a lot more of you guys
coming--whatever it is,
280 of you in this room and
there's another 280 in next
year's class and so on.
And Bill Gates knows that each
of you might come out and
threaten his monopoly,
his Microsoft monopoly.
And he might think that by
setting an example to one of you
he might be able to keep the
others out.
And somewhere that kind of
argument, the argument of making
an example of somebody is
missing here:
missing completely.
But it's got to be important,
it's got to be an important
idea.
So we're going to come back and
spend the first half of
Wednesday's class picking up
just precisely that idea.